hey y'all it's andrew couch here in this
tuesday video we're gonna be going over
our shiny modules but before i start the
dashboard
i want to say that i have a q a video
form
um linked in the description um because
i want to do a q a for my one year
anniversary
for the tidy tuesday project so you can
just submit your username which is your
youtube
name first name twitter etc and then you
can ask me a question and this question
can be about like
my background my perspective like data
science data science in general
you know interviewing advice etc i
already have
uh five responses but hopefully i can
increase that a little bit more
so with our shiny modules i'm also going
to be using the palmer penguins package
i think it's a pretty fun data set to
use um
so let's actually look at our our shiny
dashboard
i'm first going to just run it just to
show you my dashboard right now
um and this is a pretty basic dashboard
it's just showing like a summary table
with the summary statistics
a correlation plot um a
you know a principle component analysis
showing like you know
the species and the remaining species
in the components and it's also showing
like the transformation on it
and it's also showing like some pairwise
um interactions
and it's also saying like adole versus
not natalie and basically what i want to
do
is replicate this entire page or
chinstrap
and gen2 okay
now we saw my little dashboard i created
now let's actually go over um our shiny
modules
so the big idea with our shiny modules
is basically functionalizing your
um your r shiny objects or your are
shiny like
plots and tables so right now if i
wanted to really
um create um the if i wanted to finish
the dashboard with the chin strap at gen
2
i think a lot of people would kind of
like copy all the stuff paste it in
and in this case just replace like with
species equals addly
species equals gen2 species equals chin
strap
but realistically that's not the most
efficient way to do it
and it actually will um bring in some
problems say if you want to change it
so for example if i'm going to change
you know my summary table instead of
using median
i'm going to use mean i have to go
through my entire server area and
replace median
with mean do all this stuff and it could
break it on accent i could do typos
so what the entire idea with modules is
is that we can just create these as
objects just implement like a
penguin table and just give it the name
and then i'll just create the table
instantly so that way if i wanted to
basically
add some things i just add it to the
function and then load it back into the
the shiny app and it would just
automatically refresh with that contents
so let's actually start going over um a
module
and i like to think of modules as
basically mini
shiny apps so modules will always have
like a ui
and a server okay so first let's
actually create the ui
because i think the ui is the easiest
and also i want to probably create the
table first um because tables are
probably the easiest thing to create
there's not a lot of
like underworking things it's just a
simple filter
let's do that um let's create a ui so in
this case i'm just going to create a
uh table ui okay
we're gonna create a function and this
is like the function to create our
actual ui
for all these module or uh tidy um
r shiny modules we also have to give it
an id
okay and this id is basically going to
represent
our server id objects so in this case
it'd be this id would
essentially be like the add-only table
and then the auto table would be like oh
our table output is
out of table okay so now what we're
going to do is just
enter in dt data table output
and then we'll give it the ns which is
our namespace
and id and then we're actually going to
have to name this actual object's
id so we're going to call this penguin
we'll cut penguin table and this penguin
table
will essentially act as
a um as like a
pseudo id from from our object from
uh that was that we're going to create
for our server
so basically it's just saying that okay
enter table output we're going to give
it whatever comes from our server
and this server will be different
whenever we create something else
uh so if i wanted to say like adelaide
this would be a penguin table for
attaway
if i want to do a chin strap it'd be a
chin strap penguin table
um uh for a chin strap let's actually
create the table server now
um table server
function give it an id
and with the actual table server we're
gonna give it a little bit more stuff
okay so not only are we going to give it
a server
an id we need to actually determine
what's going to be cr
like what are the components that'll
create our table so in this case we're
going to have to use a data frame at
least
we'll give it an id and a data frame but
since we're also going to be filtering
we want to filter species based off some
variable
that will basically uh um give it into
the function
in this case i'm going to call it type
instead of species so
um this will be our filtering thing
that'll be basically represent you know
chinstrap
gentoo and addly okay
so now that we have our table server
we're actually have to create a module
server a module server
and we give it an id and then what we
have to do is give it a function
so function and this kind of got
this this guy this made me a little
confused because we already have a table
server but this table server
is essentially kind of like a wrapper
over our module server
the real medium potatoes is through the
module server
which is like essentially our module
right
so table server is essentially just kind
of renaming our actual module
but most of it goes into our module
server
and with our module server we're gonna
have to give it an input
an output and a session
so i don't actually know if we have to
include session um all the examples that
i was looking at
um with shiny modules always included a
session
um but since we're in the new shiny um
uh we're in the newer are shiny we don't
really include session anymore
for our apps so i'm not sure if it's
redone or not but
i figured we kind of give it a the
session just so i don't break anything
for this video
so now that we have this module server
we can basically use this
as our actual server so what we need to
include now is an
output and our output
will be called our penguin table so this
is like our penguin table far
okay and then with all of our outputs
we're gonna have to basically include
um this thing we're going to create a
render data table
and we're also going to create a data
table object for our render data table
and put in our data frame
okay so since we already gave our df
right here what we need to do now is uh
create our species
or filter based off of our species so
i'm just going to do this and copy that
in
okay and that's basically it so we have
our server
right our ui and these are essentially
going to be interacting with each other
whenever i give it a data frame and a
type
okay and i give it an id so i can create
multiple penguin tables
um because we need to specify different
ids for it
so let's actually do that right now
okay so with our uh when we're gonna put
in
our table server what we can do now
is just put in table server in our chin
strap
so table server and what we're going to
call this is the chin
wrap table our df is equal to df
and our type is equal to a chin strap
right
okay and then what we can do
is give it our
fluid row give it our box
and then we can say table ui and i can
give it my 10 strap
table let's run that and see if it works
and now we have our chin strap table
let's do the same thing for our gentoo
um actually you know what
i'm gonna do it um i'm gonna finish up
this entire
page and we'll just copy and paste into
the gen two this is
just to show you how easy it is after we
create all of our stuff
so now that we have our actual table
let's actually create some plots
so with our plots let's start with what
is it our
correlation plot which will be a simple
correlation
so what i'm going to do is i'll create a
coral
relation ui give it our id
right and then what we're going to do is
our was it
plot output given ns and i'll call it
penguin
or elation
right now we can do is we can create our
correlation
server give it our id df and
type and now we have to do is add our
module server into
that okay it's our module
server we give an id a function
an input output and
session
and in our actual server we're going to
do again
an output england
correlation oops uh was it england yeah
i have
got england correlation
give it our penguin correlation
and now let's actually put our
correlation plots in here's
copy and paste this in
right we already have our df right there
and we're just going to do a simple
type
okay
add this in so we'll do um coral
server chin strap correlation
ef equals df type is equal to chin strap
throw this into our uh
was it our um
woodrow then we'll do a coral
relation ui and pass in
our chin strap correlation what cool
let's create another fluid row and start
our other plots
uh let's do now let's do our pca plot
right so let's do the same thing um you
can see how it's getting repetitive but
again i want to show just how easy this
is to create
um so i'll do a
pca ui function id
right we do our plot output
ns id penguin we'll do
pca and then we'll do our pca
server give it our function iddf
and type
and we'll do our module server so
module server id
function input output session
and now we have our server
okay and in our server we're gonna do
our output
england pca and we're gonna basically
copy and paste this thing
in so in this case we have to do some
uh pre-processing and some pca um
creation
but it shouldn't be too crazy
okay and now what we can do is
we can change this to other
and then we can say oops if species is
equal to type
and we'll say uh we'll just say paste
zero
type and i'm pretty sure this is like a
two lower so i'll just say two lower
um and then i'll just to lower it just
so um the join
the the filtering doesn't get messed up
cool
um i think that's it for this server so
i'm just gonna
pass this in pass that in
and let's actually create our pca server
for our chin strap so pca server and
we'll say chin
trap pca df is equal to df
type is equal to pin strap
okay uh we'll put in
our uh was it pca ui
and give it our chin strap pca
lastly let's create
lastly let's create our pairs um which
is a simple ggli
okay so let's just say uh uh was it
pairs
ui function id
uh plot output and as
i id
and i'll call it penguin pairs
right nothing too crazy
um now i'll copy and paste yep and then
i'll do a pairs
server function id
df type
module server id give it an
input output and a session
and then we give it the creator to
server
now we have to create an actual object
which is a simple gg ally
again i'll just do that i'll just say uh
in this case we'll do type so
i'll say two lower oops
up to lower
and i'll say to lower
and then we'll say always say other just
because i don't feel like
doing a lot of uh um pasting and uh
string
manipulation so i'll say paste zero type
cool and that's actually create this
error server and we'll say chin strap
pairs
ef is equal to pdf
type is equal to chin strap
okay now let's actually create
our little um
our actual plot so we'll say errors
ui and pass it in
let's run this app and see if it
actually works
oh pinstripe i'm excited for chin strap
pca data from output
okay so let's see what our
our pca did
vca server
oh there it is
oh i forgot to do the render plots thing
so render
what
oops i'm just gonna
module server given id
a function input output session
there you go output uh penguin
pca render
plot and then we'll do that
and then what would say is our output
uh penguin
yeah no i don't ever did the output
sorry about that
okay
uh-oh
and that penguin pca
render plot
oh there it is i i did that
pca
oh and then this is with the pairs okay
and i'm sure i did the same thing with
the pairs on accent
yep and i forgot that so we'll just do
render
what and then we'll do
sorry about that um doing this live is
not as
um i'm not as good as doing this live as
i thought it was
okay
and now we have our our plot right here
we can see our chin strap versus other
chin strap versus other we can go to uh
gentoo which will do gentoo other
hopefully
oh and i didn't even do that and i am a
little scatterman it's because
um i definitely uh still need to get
better with uh remembering to do render
plot
after all these uh other server all
these module server functions
because essentially it's like function
within a function within a function um
so that's kind of confusing but what we
can do
right now is i can show you how easy it
is to create
um the same thing after
um we went through it so i'll just say
right here
right there right there
of that paste paste paste paste
go back to here being essentially copy
this
right there
there and right there
and right there wait
and we have our gen 2 so as you can see
it was pretty
fast for me to actually create the gen 2
page after i created these functions and
what we can do now
is i can just remove all of this
right and we can do the same thing
right here we'll say paste paste paste
paste
uh i'll paste that
okay we'll paste it right there
i could probably just do a search and
replace but this is only four fine
and i can then remove all this garbage
which all actually is
so we'll do that and then we can do is
actually i'll probably just right here
i'll do a find a chin
strap place
oh right there
now what we can do is run this app
and we can see we have the exact same
app
but everything is modularized um it's in
a module
it's functionalized it's clean and
what we can see here is it's a very
simple looking app
right it's just saying oh you have a
table you know your table ui your
correlation uh your pairs ui your pca ui
you give it a different name because
you're creating different objects
they're dependent
on my filtering in my server
um and all this stuff right here can
actually be
um brought in from like an r script
functions
when we can just source out like that
another thing which i think i'll
probably make another video on
is doing essentially nested modules so
as you can see we're basically
uh redoing this little segment
over and over again what we can actually
do is create these into a module
and just say this is the atlea page
but i think i'll probably do that for a
future video
so um i know this is a pretty quick
video it's about 20 minutes long
but i think modules are actually pretty
simple
there's there's just a bunch of odd
syntax
but once you actually get the server
syntax right with the module server
and understand that you know when you
have these nested functions that
they're essentially just um they're not
really doing that much
it's mostly you doing most uh pacing
most of the work in the module server
um you can get the hang of it so with
that being said
i'll see you guys next week and tidy on